[Musique]
le vol d'identité est ce que ça vous
fait pas
en tout cas les assureurs proposent
maintenant de vous protéger contre ce
risque nous avons consulté trois experts
en cybercriminalité en cyber sécurité et
en consommation on leur demandait est ce
que ça vaut la peine leurs réponses non
serait départ d'abord il faut savoir que
ces assurances ne remboursent pas les
pertes financières dues à la fraude elle
vous indemnise pour les démarches que
vous ferez pour rétablir votre
réputation journées non travaillées
conseils juridiques etc ensuite il y
avoue le vol d'identité vous inquiète un
peu ou rouge beaucoup piocher une
quinzaine d'heures pour rétablir votre
crédit vous paraît accessible ou
insurmontable à ces deux questions si
vous avez des geôles doigt sur le bouton
panique cette assurance est peut-être
pour vous évidemment il ya toute une
gamme de produits le 24 à 3 160 dollars
par année mais sachez que plusieurs
compagnies offrent déjà cette protection
gratuitement à leurs assurés
d'enseignement à je jette un oeil
là-dessus pascal